um dia três presentes três presentes pra
vocês da minha vida tá eu tenho uma vida
acadêmica tenho minha vida científica
mas eu não trouxe nada disso pra você
trouxe três presentes meus da minha vida
o primeiro presente é falar sobre o
talento
mesmo quando você não tenha nenhum
o segundo presente é a receita da
infelicidade que desgraça não trouxe um
presente que chama a receita da
infelicidade e o terceiro presente a
fonte da juventude
tem algum valor
o talento é o seguinte quando eu era
pequeno eu queria ser um cientista da
nasa era mais ou menos 1970 quando eu
era muito pequeno e o homem tinha
acabado de a lua e eu era nerd antes da
palavra nerd existir
você já deve ter visto aqueles dvds que
você compra você nunca comprou lógico
mas você já viu aqui em dvd pirata em
que alguém vai no cinema e gravar o
filme com uma câmera zinha vocês não
sabem disso vocês nunca compraram em
1982 quando passou o império
contra-ataca quer o segundo filme de
guerra nas estrelas
quando eu estava na sexta vez assistindo
no cinema porque só tinha cinema para
você assistir que assistiu ao estilo que
nos tiram assistir mais quando eu sentei
e tinha mais
acho que 12 pessoas no cinema lá em
londrina eu tirei o gravador gravador de
fita cassete casa fita cassete um
negócio que você coloca em gravar desse
tamanho e coloquei no meu colo antes do
filme começar porque eu ia gravar o som
quer fazer disse antes da do dos piratas
a desistirem e talvez eu tenha sido um
dos precursores do piratex mas o fato é
que quando eu olhei pro lado dois caras
começaram na
usada porque o filme ainda não tinha
começado eles viram eu pegando gravador
e colocando o qual eles começaram a dar
risada e olhei pra ele eu falei porque
estão vindo e cada um tirou o gravador
do colo também só que eles não tinham
tirado antes porque ele estava com
vergonha eles achavam que o cara do
cinema tirar eles bom é bom resume a
história acabei conhecendo eles porque
maluco de ímã a gente se conectou e
depois eu comprei um filme de máquina
fotográfica tcheco era muito caro quero
mais amil que conseguiria que conseguirá
tirar foto no escuro ea gente se cotizou
pra comprar um rolo de 36 filme filme é
um negócio assim que você coloca na
máquina fotográfica tira foto ea gente
tinha 36 fotos da próxima sessão do
governo nas estrelas e cada um tinha uma
quota de 12 cenas para escolher mas todo
mundo já sabia de cabeça qual cena seria
que ele queria que fotografasse então no
outro filme na outra sessão das outras
que a gente foi a agente não falta do
filme mas como era muito nerd queria ser
um cientista da nasa eu achei que eu
deveria fazer física
meu pai era feirante minha família
diferentes quando eu falei que queria
fazer física meu pai entendeu que era
educação física ele ficou maluco e
começou a brigar com a minha irmã porque
falando assim mas ele vai fazer educação
física porque o sonho do meu pai era ter
um filho médico a gente era éramos em
seis irmãos todo mundo ia pra feira
trabalhar mais um tinha que salvar a
família
o ec padre ia ser médico é então eu era
mais ou menos o inteligente da família
pra ver que minha família não era muito
bem dotada eu era mais inteligente da
minha família mas quando eu passei no
vestibular eu tive uma grande alegria e
uma grande angústia a grande alegria foi
eu passei no vestibular quer dizer eu
sou alguma coisa inteligente porque eu
passei no vestibular mas eu passei
medicina
o talento que eu tinha que eu sabia que
eu tinha que era ser um pouco
inteligente ou não ser bonito no nosso
alto na sede olho azul e também no 11
não era é
fisicamente dotado em termos de esporte
então eu era inteligente talvez na
faculdade inteira as minhas notas foram
as piores do que eu precisava estudar
quatro vezes mais do que todo mundo
porque todo tudo aquilo que se falava
ali na aula que todo mundo se deliciava
com a medicina pra mim não fazia nada
sentido a minha cabeça tava em
tecnologia
desde aquela época então foram os piores
anos da minha vida a faculdade de
medicina
depois que terminei a faculdade eu
resolvi redirecionar a minha vida eu
falei agora vou tomar a vida nas mãos de
novo e como eu acho que eu sou
inteligente não vou fazer aquilo que os
outros fazem e eu vou jogar meu diploma
fora e vou dar o meu pai não pensei
assim eu devo ser mais inteligente do
que isso eu vou usar essa base dessa
inteligência que lhe resta para tentar
salvar a minha vida e decidi fazer
futurologia não por causa do olho
machucado das máquinas
a vida me levou para um caminho em que o
meu talento não valia mais
ou seja eu achava desde criança que era
inteligente e mesmo na oftalmologia eu
preciso me esforçar quatro vezes mais do
que os colegas para chegar em algum
lugar eu virei chefe do setor de
catarata catarata cirurgia mais uma das
cirurgias mais realizadas do mundo e
chefe do setor de catarata da escola
paulista de medicina a ef sexy
aí eu fiquei bonito é segunda vantagem e
o que me levou do ponto a quando era
criança que eu achava que era
inteligente para o ponto b
certamente não foi na inteligência
mesmo porque na escola paulista unifesp
inteligência commodity ser inteligente é
igualmente a cabelo aqui tá pelo menos
você prende o cabelo e também depois
inteligente
eu descobri que o que me levou do ponto
a para o ponto b foi à residência
eu vou falar uma coisa eu nunca disse
que eu aprendi com a vida com outros
eventos que aconteceram na minha vida
que se mostraram como obstáculos que eu
nunca desistir
e olha só que interessante hoje lidando
com mentes brilhantes nas equipes com o
seu trabalho
o trabalho em vários hospitais hoje
gosto de trabalhar com jovens todos
acham que têm talento que tem talento e
é legal porque tem mais talento do que
eu porque como fazem medicina e fazem
uma especialidade biológica eles têm uma
uma naturalidade e aprender muito mais
rápido do que eu invejo eu sou professor
deles mas eu tenho que estudar quatro
vezes mais pra pelo menos empatar com
eles mas hoje eu vejo não mais a
inteligência porque pra mim inteligência
commodity
eu procuro resiliência e eu vou falar
pra vocês é difícil encontrar eu já dei
muito talentoso não chegar no ponto b
muito talentoso
porque não tinha residência e à
juventude de hoje não está refletindo
sobre a residência
então como como uma mensagem final dessa
primeira parte eu diria o seguinte eu
tenho uma notícia boa notícia ruim
a notícia boa é que ao contrário de ser
nascer mais bonito
o nascer naturalmente inteligente
resiliência não é um dom que deus deu
pra você e para alguns tempo alguns não
têm resiliência todo mundo tem
residência uma escolha é uma opção é
você fala assim eu vou até o fim
existem uma série de critérios para você
escolher os projetos ou as metas pelos
que você vai direcionar sua vida mas em
última instância o que faz você chegar
lá na frente é a residência não é o
talento
a gente se engana quando a gente vê um
grande artista um grande esportista que
chegou lá ea gente fala ele nasceu
virado pra lua não não
a gente não tem bastidor que a gente não
vê o dia a dia dele a gente vê as pingas
que ele não deu tons eleva e todo mundo
lá button e levar tombo faz parte da
vida da minha segunda parte que eu falei
pra vocês que eu vim aqui trazer receita
da fé infelicidade
a receita da infelicidade é importante é
um presente pra vocês xavi deu bem aqui
e ele me dar de presente a receita da
infelicidade
você tem que entender o que a receita da
infelicidade porque a contrapartida da
receita da infelicidade é a felicidade
tá todo mundo busca a felicidade mas não
sabe qual é a receita da infelicidade a
receita da infelicidade
ela é bem simples ea gente aprende
quando a gente adulto quando a gente é
criança a gente não sabe disso
a receita da infelicidade a primeira são
dois pontos a receita da infelicidade é
vai atrás do que os outros têm
eu vejo muita gente perdendo a vida
adulta indo atrás do que o outro tempo
eu achava que isso era uma coisa de
criança né eu tenho você não tem o
adulto leva isso a sério mas o duto leva
muito a sério ele criou até mídia social
para fazer isso a rede social para fazer
isso eu tenho você não tem eu tô você
não tá eu estou viajando você não tá
isso é muito sério e é uma bela receita
da felicidade
ou seja você ir atrás do que os outros
têm do que os outros fazem
você vê uma foto postada na rede social
e mostrando ele muito feliz com alguma
coisa então nós logicamente você pensa
assim
se ele é feliz com aquela coisa eu
também se eu tiver aquela coisa você
feliz isso é um grande engano
eu adoro star wars e se eu levar vocês
pra ficar numa maratona de três dias de
star wars
eu garanto que vai ser um inferno a
segunda o segundo ponto para a receita
da infelicidade é vai atrás do dinheiro
é muito simples eu conheço muita gente
eu conheço muita gente pobre que só tem
dinheiro
eu tenho dó tem muito dinheiro e só tem
eu tenho muita dó e verdade é um total
de boca pra fora eu conheço pessoas são
pessoas que eu conheço eu tenho relação
que eu tenho dó porque eu vejo assim
eles ainda estão perdendo a vida a vida
a gente não tem uma segunda chance na
vida
ontem existe esse negócio de educação e
tudo mas preço partindo do pressuposto
eu não acredito mas partindo do
pressuposto que a gente só tem uma vida
gastar ela com dinheiro indo atrás de
dinheiro é a sua receita da felicidade
qual é o segredo então da felicidade
ela não está fora do nosso alcance
a receita da felicidade é você olhar a
criança que existe dentro de você
quando a gente era criança a gente só
fazer o que gostava que a gente fala
assim puxa uma experiência pouco ela só
faz o que gosta
você já foi criança você já foi assim
também
se você ouvir essa criança e você parar
pra escutar essa criança e levar a sério
ela ela vai ter suas respostas
há muitos anos atrás de plantão com uma
moça que a gente começa a conversar
achava sexo fala de star wars não é que
eu ia ganhar pontos
aí ela falou assim eu gosto muito de
star trek star trek jornada nas estrelas
que a outra desgraça
existe uma rixa entre os dois que é
outro ted
e ela falava assim e aí eu falei pra ela
assim eu gosto muito fácil tal coisa eu
faço aeronaves e outras coisas sexies e
ela falou assim eu gosto muito de
jornada nas estrelas desde jovens
assistia os filmes mas eu parei porque
todo mundo acha bobeira isso né
a chover é uma coisa idiota todo mundo
dá risada aqui eu falei pra ela sandra
a única pessoa que tem que levar em
consideração importante levar a sério é
você e mais ninguém senão você esperar
que alguém respeite eu gosto disso
bom vou resumir ela voltou isso em 1992
ela voltou a ler sobre isso não tinha
internet do senado ela encontrou um
grupo de de como é que um grupo de
encontro de jornada nas estrelas onde
não tinha internet não sei como se
encontravam uma vez por mês um sábado
maluco tem imã
ela foi convidada para traduzir os
livros de jornada nas estrelas no brasil
pela editora que lançou anos depois
quando encontraram no congresso ela
falou assim eu passei duas semanas na
nasa porque o pensamento de uma
engenheira médica lá e eu passei duas
semanas a nasa e cada dia que eu tava lá
lembrava de você
quanto vale sem dinheiro
a terceira mensagem é sobre a fonte da
juventude
se a coisa cara pra mim é uma coisa
muito cara aos 25 anos eu me sentia
muito velho porque eu falei assim mongol
de medicina estudo sobre medicina pelo
phd em hidrologia da tecnologia
cardiologia dermatologia gastronomia eu
sabia tudo na vida já tinha estudado
todo então eu me sentia velho velho em
londrina e eu tinha um favor de me
pensar que eu estava velho
quando eu vim pra são paulo e era um
caipira não saber pegar o ônibus
eu não sabia que é
dona rosa eu não sabia entrar no metrô
eu não sabia ligar um aparelho de alta
tecnologia e eu descobri assim nossa
cada vez que eu não sei alguma coisa tem
que reaprender neste processo também
como eu já estava me aborrecendo mas eu
falava assim como eu fujo da sensação de
velho e houve duas coisas que eu achava
legal como todo jovem é aquela idéia
errônea de achar sem dinheiro é uma
fonte de juventude e aí eu vi aquela
história de que eu de pessoas que tinham
dinheiro não tinha mais nada eu pensei
então poder é uma coisa legal poder
bacana assim o cara é dono de um
hospital o dono de uma empresa e mantém
todo mundo então ele se sente renovado
contínuo e aí bom eu vi várias para
situações em que isso era errado por
exemplo donald trump agora então se nem
poder e nem dinheiro pra mim pelo menos
era fonte da juventude o que era a fonte
da juventude
e eu fui andando na minha caminhada de
resiliência e conectando logo na
primeira parte e eu vi que cada vez que
eu precisava aprender alguma coisa do
zero eu me senti uma criança de novo a
criança
cada vez que eu precisava aprender a
odiar o metrô a ligar um aparelho ou
estudar uma matéria que não sabia eu me
sentia uma criança de novo
e olha só aprender alguma coisa estudar
alguma coisa se tornou um meio de vida
pra mim eu virei professor sem nunca ter
querido ser professor e eu tô aqui na
escola paulista treinando fesp
não porque eu sei mais porque eu
descobri que saber - é mais legal saber
- é muito sexy
eu descobri a fonte da juventude
cada vez que eu encontro alguma matéria
nova alguma tecnologia nova
na minha área
uma técnica cirúrgica nova eu falo que
bom que mas que bom mesmo
que bom porque eu tenho que aprender e
eu não sei nada sobre isso
então essa fonte da juventude pra mim é
a coisa mais cara da minha vida cada vez
que eu descubro que eu não sei alguma
coisa eu reconheço tudo de novo eu falo
para os meus alunos em inglês feitor
abrace a queda
faça as pazes com a queda a vida não é
rede social em que tudo dá certo eu só
coloco os meus sucessos
essa é a famosa na infelicidade quando
você faz as pazes com seus próprios
sucessos
a vida tem um colorido próprio que não
está na internet
esse colorido próprio é diferente do que
a juventude às vezes hoje que pensar que
a vida só vale a pena se for só cor de
rosa como por mini pônei né
não havia uma desgraça se for só assim a
vida seria um lixo se fosse só isso
as infelicidades e as quedas são
maravilhosos na nossa vida
então seja residente ou sua criança
interior e abrace a infelicidade ea
queda
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]